[Música]
Hola Yo soy Natalia Cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a América este es el
magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente Y esta es lo que
veremos hoy
déjà Vu by the nitrom se disputarán la
presidencia de Estados Unidos en las
elecciones de 2024 el presidente
estadounidense confirmó que aspirará a
la reelección al igual que el
expresidente Donald Trump sin otros
aspirantes fuertes ni en el partido
demócrata ni en el republicano se prevé
que ambos serán confirmados en las
convenciones de cada partido
y en Colombia el presidente Gustavo
Petro se posicionó más hacia la
izquierda tras romper la coalición de
gobierno debido a diferencias con los
partidos conservadores sobre sus
reformas y reemplazó a siete de sus
ministros lo que lo llevó a la segunda
crisis de gabinete en menos de un año
que llevan el poder
y esta semana en Brasil se celebró el
Camp Terra libre 2023 La tradicional
movilización indígena desde los
territorios ancestrales hasta Brasilia
para pedir atención al gobierno de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva sobre la pérdida
de los mismos que los ha obligado a huir
a las ciudades
y vamos de inmediato a Estados Unidos
para nuestra historia principal el
actual presidente Joe biden disipó las
dudas y confirmó que aspira a la
reelección por el partido demócrata si
lo logra el que ya es el mandatario de
más edad de la historia de la nación
saldrá de la Casa Blanca a los 86 años
bailena había evadido las críticas sobre
su edad en la primera elección frente a
Donald Trump en 2020 al decir que no
aspiraría un segundo mandato y dejaría
que en su lugar lo hiciera el actual
vicepresidenta kamala Harris de 58 años
sin embargo año y medio de las
elecciones y tras el revés en los
comicios de medio término en los que
perdieron el control total del Congreso
no había margen de error para los
demócratas ahora las elecciones de 2024
son un déjà Vu biden versus Trump así lo
justificó el presidente estadounidense
es hora de terminar el trabajo terminar
el trabajo
[Aplausos]
Gracias tenemos mucho más trabajo por
hacer sé que la gente también está
luchando contra la inflación La amenaza
que suponen los republicanos del hacer a
Estados Unidos grande de nuevo para
llevarnos a un lugar en el que nunca
hemos estado
los republicanos respondieron con un
vídeo de Inteligencia artificial en el
que criticaron al que consideran es el
peor presidente de la historia y que
opte por cuatro años más en la oficina
oval sin embargo no hicieron mucho eco
sobre el tema de la edad puesto que el
que también es prácticamente confirmado
como candidato y digo prácticamente pues
ambos deben ser oficializados en la
convención nacional de los partidos
Trump tiene 76 años El Magnate volvió a
repetir sin fundamento que biden le robó
las elecciones anteriores
una presidencia con tantas calamidades
es casi inconcebible que Joe biden
siquiera considerar a ser candidato a la
reelección ustedes saben lo que pasó en
la anterior elección hicieron trampa y
se robaron las elecciones pero les
prometo esto cuando debatamos y
comparemos nuestros historiales va a ser
la peor pesadilla de los radicales
demócratas porque nunca ha habido un
récord tan malo como esto y nuestro país
nunca ha estado peor nunca ha habido un
contraste tan grande entre dos
administraciones en la historia de
Estados Unidos con la de nosotros siendo
grandiosa y la de ellos un fracaso
un adelanto de lo que será la campaña
difusión de información falsa sobre los
comicios de 2020 Y probablemente al
igual que en 2020 más ataques que
propuestas Esto es lo que piensan los
ciudadanos al respecto
estoy un poco molesta es un poco viejo y
si no puede unirme al ejército a los 58
No creo que él deba gobernar el país a
los 80 y cuántos años tendrá 84 es
demasiado viejo definitivamente
demasiado
para mí es una buena noticia sí estoy
contenta con este presidente en este
momento y creo que es una buena
alternativa para las próximas elecciones
sí creo que hay muchas cosas por hacer
en el futuro y estoy feliz con esta
noticia
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
realizó el mayor cambio dentro de su
gabinete y sustituyó a siete de sus 18
ministros incluyendo el de Hacienda El
de agricultura y el de salud también
disolvió la coalición de gobierno con
tres partidos tradicionales luego de que
estos no los respaldaran en la reforma a
la salud Andrés triviño nos cuenta más
ministerial en Colombia a casi 9 meses
de haber asumido su cargo el presidente
Gustavo Petro cambió a siete de sus 18
ministros y a un alto funcionario de la
presidencia así respondió cuando tres
partidos tradicionales que hacían parte
del gobierno no lo respaldaron en su
criticada reforma a la salud que cursan
el congreso la cual prioriza la atención
primaria y quiere eliminar el manejo por
parte de empresas privadas además Petro
disolvió la coalición gubernamental por
lo que pierde las mayorías en el
legislativo hoy se construye un nuevo
gabinete que ayudará a consolidar el
programa de gobierno programa que será
la base de un acuerdo nacional Franco y
sincero Para seguir trabajando al
servicio de las comunidades de todo el
país uno de los anuncios que más
sorprendió fue el relevo de la ministra
de salud Carolina corcho quien dio la
batalla para defender la reforma a la
salud por otro lado salen el ministro de
hacienda José Antonio Ocampo y de
agricultura Cecilia López los dos habían
firmado una carta con críticas a dicha
reforma antes de que fuera presentada
ambos sobrevivieron a la anterior crisis
de gabinete en febrero cuando el
presidente hizo sus tres primeros
cambios otra cara de la actual
modificación ministerial es que tres de
los nuevos funcionarios trabajaron con
Petro cuando él fue alcalde de Bogotá
entre 2012 y 2015 con el nuevo equipo el
primer presidente de izquierda de
Colombia aún tiene un largo camino por
recorrer para lograr su plan de gobierno
denominado el pacto social por el cambio
y actualmente tiene una desfavorabilidad
del
57%, casi tres veces mayor que la que
tenía a un mes de iniciar su mandato
y seguimos en Colombia Pero esta vez
para hablar de Venezuela el presidente
Pedro convocó una conferencia
internacional para buscar una salida de
la crisis a esta no estaban invitados ni
el chavismo ni la oposición pero si
delegaciones de 20 países la cita dejó
tres conclusiones según informó el
canciller colombiano Álvaro Leyva un
cronograma electoral el levantamiento de
sanciones y la necesidad de inversión
social no obstante no hay una fecha
concreta para continuar los diálogos
entre el oficialismo venezolano y la
oposición en México
y Mientras tanto en Venezuela la
sociedad de pediatría alertó sobre los
bajos índices de vacunación a los
médicos les preocupa que resurjan
enfermedades erradicadas como la
difteria según algunos de ellos
consultados por france24 actualmente el
sector público cuenta con apenas entre
el 50 y el 60% de las dosis de vacunas
necesarias para cubrir a toda la
población el informe desde Caracas es de
Daniela Zambrano
en Venezuela la escasez de vacunas en el
sector público y los altos precios en el
sector privado entre 100 y 140 dólares
por dosis han dificultado la vacunación
del hijo menor de Corina Pereira Mira
las tres vacunas que le faltan a Guille
sería el equivalente a una mensualidad y
media de colegio de uno de ellos
para los hijos de luisana carrillos más
difícil el acceso a la vacunación porque
dependen de la salud pública donde las
vacunas suelen llegar de forma
intermitente Mira no le conseguí esta
esta vacuna otras como rotavirus y
neumococo no están disponibles desde
hace más de cinco años a veces se las
consigo como a veces no se la consigo
entonces a veces me hacen madrugar con
la bebé Entonces resulta que si son 10
niños el frasquito no se puede este
exactamente son a diez niños que se le
tienen que colocar si yo llegué a la
después del número 11 ya no me la
colocan tengo que volver a madrugar
seguro la falta de vacunas según los
especialistas se debe a la deuda que
mantiene el estado venezolano con el
fondo rotatorio de la organización
paramericana de la salud que ronda los
11 millones de dólares sin poder comprar
el gobierno apenas recibe algunas
donaciones y los bajos niveles de
vacunación son alarmantes
aproximadamente la disponibilidad de
vacunas entre un 50 y 60 por ciento de
las dosis que deberían tenerse Entonces
nada más tenemos 50 60 por ciento
cubierto del esquema que debería tener
un paciente en general pediátrico la
principal preocupación del gremio médico
y de madres como Corina luisana es que
emerjan enfermedades antes erradicadas
un caso de difteria registrado en
febrero en el estado Bolívar encendió
nuevamente las alarmas entre 2016 y 2019
un brote de la enfermedad causó la
muerte de al menos 291 venezolanos según
cifras de la Ops y para terminar nos
vamos a Brasil datos preliminares del
censo de 2022 señalan que hay uno coma
seis millones de indígenas casi el doble
de lo que apuntaba el recuento anterior
al menos 320.000 viven en áreas urbanas
aunque se estima que esta cifra podría
aumentar en un país donde el crecimiento
agrícola amenaza Cada día los
territorios protegidos muchos de ellos
se ven obligados a huir hacia la ciudad
el informe es de nuestra corresponsal en
Río de Janeiro Valeria sacone coloco un
nombre sagrado en nuestra máquina para
destruir nuestra naturaleza que es eso
maradei es el nombre de nuestra tierra
sagrada
en guaraní maraei significa Tierra sin
mal los indígenas de la aldea mata verde
bonita en el estado de Río de Janeiro
protestan contra la construcción de un
Macro complejo turístico un juez
dictaminó el bloqueo de las obras pero
la empresa española responsable del
proyecto recorrió con el apoyo de los
poderes locales
en mi pueblo ahora por la mañana
cortaron estos árboles 23 Cuántos
árboles cortaron aquí este árbol nos
proporciona semillas para nuestros
collares
40 familias viven en esta restinga
protegida por Su riqueza medioambiental
estamos en maricá el municipio que
acumula el mayor crecimiento del pib de
Brasil gracias a los royalties del
petróleo
pero esta riqueza no llega a la
población indígena que mal vive en casas
de barro
Mira cómo están nuestras casas esta paja
está desapareciendo aquí de nuestra
región por eso nuestras casas Están en
malas condiciones
estos guaraníes fueron realojados aquí
hace una década tras ser expulsados de
una región vecina por la especulación
edilicia nunca recibieron los títulos de
propiedad de las tierras no se oponen a
la construcción de un Resort de lujo
pero en contrapartida exigen al
ayuntamiento que invierta en saneamiento
y en salud
estaldea guaraní atrapada entre los
rascacielos de San Pablo es el símbolo
de la resistencia de los indígenas ante
el avance de la presión urbanística
hoy tenemos a líderes que
lamentablemente tuvieron que irse de
nuestra comunidad porque sufrían
amenazas de Invasores que están ocupando
y vendiendo lotes de tierra dentro de
nuestra comunidad
Aquí viven 700 personas repartidas en
seis aldeas en su momento fue la región
indígena de marcada más pequeña del país
posee tan solo 1,73 hectáreas
es que fue atropellado ya tuvimos niños
atropellados aquí por causa de la
división que los no indígenas hicieron
en nuestra aldea para poder llegar al
centro de Sao Paulo
estos indígenas urbanos son
discriminados por los blancos de la
ciudad y también por los nativos de las
reservas que los critican por haber
perdido sus tradiciones y su lengua
original
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí América por favor envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvo Andrés doncell Sigan
viendo France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]